so the terrain here is definitely
getting steeper and more committing but
you know so much so survival is about
just trying to be resourceful I just
wonder if maybe we maybe use that old
trunk
use that get that down and then we could
down climb that let's have a look at
anything there's some way we can use our
axe to make a ladder out of that yeah
brilliant brilliant
totally maybe if we like cut a little
steps into it it doesn't have to be big
you know just enough to use his hands
and feet drag it drop it down maybe tie
this rope the end of it so it stays in
place to pass his old log on the way
down have you got that axe on you let's
bring the axe up here and of course cuz
he s so dry out here nothing really
wrought rock-hard though this wood but
whatever it was used for one time we're
gonna use it for our purpose which is
getting down this crack so they could
give us the axe what we're trying to do
is trying to get we could cut some
little steps into it and drop it down
this crack and use those and down climb
[Music]
let's get you doing a bit of that we get
this right ready and then we're it's a
bear's plan is to somehow climb down
this log ladder that we've built for
Mark two hands in the max okay so it's a
bunch of steps cut and now we're gonna
do its position this so you take the
heavy end
I'll take this end you already know
we're going down to the right yeah
literally like he's moving a matchstick
well the great thing about having dave
bautista on this journey is that when
you're moving heavy tree trunks around
it suddenly all becomes a little bit
easier okay just step down there we'll
let gravity do the work now if you put
it down I feel okay climbing down this
log right now but as Mike Tyson said
everybody who always has a plan until
they get punched in the face so I'll see
you oh it starts looking worried when
we're actually doing this but as of
right now I'm extremely confident when I
go down am I going down like keeping my
weight on the rope or should I try to
balance myself they bit of both little
bit of both yes it gets steeper it's
gonna be more natural to use your hands
and stuff and you know graffiti as well
so okay
[Music]
okay tell me when you're at the top
no yet Thomas okay cuz I'm gonna I'm
struggling to hold you on that one
you talking to me you wanna I can't see
you now yeah I'm on the log and these
notches are with further point than I
thought
okay I'm down I made it okay good job
okay I'm gonna follow you down this line
that were pretty good in there yeah I
was a little scaring there was a couple
times so I just wanted to wrap myself
around the lobby hopefully slide down
[Music]
you